[Music]
so we have a wonderful panel here
tonight our next participant is a
professor at the Institute for Advanced
Study at Princeton he has made many
influential and creative contributions
to our understanding of the early
universe particle astrophysics and
cosmology as probes of fundamental
physics
please welcome Matias Alda Ryoga
our next guest is a theorist with a
wide-ranging interests in fundamental
physics from high-energy physics and
string theory to cosmology and Collider
physics he was a professor of physics at
Berkeley at Harvard and Harvard before
joining the Institute for Advanced Study
in 2008
please welcome Nima or Akane Hamid
our final participant is an
astrophysicist whose multitude of
scientific contributions include
observations and experimental
astrophysics and spaceborne
instrumentation she served as NASA's
chief scientist and received the
agency's highest honor the Distinguished
Service Medal currently she is ahead of
the 7.5 billion dollar independent
federal agency charged with advancing
this scientific discovery technological
innovation and science education
please welcome director of the National
Science Foundation France a Cordova
[Applause]
so first let me just try to set the
stage for our conversation here the past
few decades have been fairly spectacular
for fundamental physics on the grand
scale of the cosmos we have not only
detected the Cosmic Microwave Background
which is you know the afterglow of the
Big Bang but also by measuring the
properties of this radiation especially
of the fluctuations in this thing we
were able to confirm a broad-brush
picture of our universe what is within
it what its properties are we determined
six parameters to high accuracy that
determine our universe we know now a lot
about you know what the universe is made
of we know that ordinary matter for
example the stuff that we're made of
stars are made of galaxies are made of
is less than 5% of the cosmic energy
budget about 25% or so it's dark matter
which is matter that while has a
gravitational influence it does not emit
or absorb any light the rest 70% is in
the form of some smooth form that fills
all space which we sometimes call dark
energy it's consistent with Einstein's
famous cosmological constant we measured
the expansion rate of the universe and
we know that rate locally with an error
no bigger than 2.4 percent which means
we can determine the age of the universe
with that type of accuracy I actually
looked it up and it turns out that the
all the medical techniques we have today
we cannot determine the age of a person
with that type of accuracy but we can
determine the age of the universe with
that so this is on the grand scale of
things on the small scale we have a
standard model of particle physics where
we know what we think are the basic
constituents of matter
these are quark
leptons we also know that there are
force for forced carriers you know
carrier of the electromagnetic of the
weak of the strong interaction and this
culminated in 2012 with the discovery of
the Higgs boson or at least a particle
that has those properties which is again
associated with the field that permeates
all space and which gives mass we think
to all the particles that we all know in
love so this is also an amazing
achievement we discover it for the first
time men managed to detect gravitational
waves these are ripples in space-time
predicted by Einstein's theory of
general relativity and for looked for
for decades and we finally found them so
this is all amazing now in spite of all
of these enormous successes there have
been a few surprises and some might even
say disappointments at some level so for
example in the Cosmic Microwave
Background
there is a strong prediction from our
model which is called inflation that you
know the universe with one morning it
was a tiny fraction of a second all
expended like crazy that there should be
some imprint in the Cosmic Microwave
Background in the form of polarization
some some form now those have not been
detected yet this does not mean they are
not there
it's just that they haven't been yet
detected in the particle physics side
there have been strong predictions or
expectations I should say that in the
Large Hadron Collider we will discover
supersymmetry
that namely that each particle that we
all know and love would have a partner
that has a spin that is half a unit
removed from that those haven't been
detected yet the mass of the Higgs boson
was surprised to some and in particular
it was thought that maybe the mass that
was found means that there should be
other particles in its vicinity those
were not found so basically we
understand now that there is still a lot
of work to be done so now I will turn to
the participants here and you know let's
see how we can make progress so I will
start by asking each one of you to tell
me very briefly I mean in something like
three minutes what are you working on
right now so enticed with you my dear so
right now I'm working on two things so
I'm very interested in the things that
could be left over from the very
beginning from the beginning of the hot
Big Bang in the form of these small
fluctuations that then grow to form the
structure that we see in the universe
and the good thing about them is that
they have a lot of memory so when we
look at things today we can kind of play
back the picture and try to understand
how they started and I'm interested in
several of those properties and I'm
working in trying to improve the ways
the ways that we run these movie
backwards to try to extract more
information about how things started
because that's to me one of the big
mysteries nema well I'm thinking about
things on the two extremes that you
alluded to on the very very short
distance frontier a very high energy
frontier for the past number of years
I've been thinking a lot about how we
could experimentally study in as much
detail as possible and what we could
learn if we got this experimental
information about properties of the
Higgs particle the ex parte achill is a
very strange particle we've never seen
anything like it before and it's more
more a more point like than you would
naively expect it to be maybe there's no
struck yeah that doesn't seem to have
any any structure seems to be like like
purely point like doesn't seem to have
any sub sub structure at all
and a whole bunch of people are or are
studying the prospects of having another
accelerator after the LHC could be a
hundred kilometers around and one of the
things that would do is is put the Higgs
under a much more powerful microscope
than we could get from the LHC and
answer very basic questions that are
going to be left open even after we
finish running everything about the LHC
about this but a burning theoretical
mystery about its sub sub structure in
the opposite direction of literally
working on on the train on the way up
here is has to do with some questions
about the cosmology cosmology is this
the most glorious of the historical
sciences but like all historical
Sciences it has an interesting
relationship but the notion of time none
of us were around during the early
universe but we infer this past and the
Big Bang and even inflation and all this
stuff because we make measurement today
at very late times about sort of
correlations in space and we decide that
the best way of making sense of those
correlations in space is by inferring
the existence of a time and a
cosmological time and evolution that
came before that a lot like a
paleontologist infers the existence of
dinosaurs from the existence of big
bones lying around but for many reasons
we expect the notion of time has got to
ultimately break down it can't be
fundamental especially when you get back
to the Big Bang probably it's a notion
of time which is breaking down so that
suggests theoretically there should be
some way of talking about things without
making such heavy use of this concept of
time and so I've been working
theoretically on trying to find some
interesting new mathematical structures
that could replace time and our
understanding before these spatial
correlations come right and time would
in that sense be an emergent property an
emergent armory okay thanks friends I
realized that you know you are it's it's
somewhat different in terms of what you
saw in your case I would insist on I
mean what is currently most occupying
you know your time I run a big agency
that funds all of science and
engineering everything except for the
biomedical sciences which the National
Institutes of Health does so we fund
everything from Social and Behavioral
Sciences to geosciences biological
sciences computer sciences clearly
physics astronomy chemistry material
sciences mathematics and and so on I'm
sure I left something out we also run
the u.s. Antarctica program and so we
have a lot of science there at the South
Pole including an experiment that's
called ice cube which is a big neutrino
detector at the South Pole of about us
we're Kilometre Array of photo
multipliers that are they go down
kilometer into the ice and detect
neutrinos from the heavens but on the
practical side of serving science we're
building some very big telescopes for
the future and we're also trying to make
better the telescopes that we currently
have so it's one example on the
gravitational wave experiment we know
there are lots of noise that affects the
the spectrum of the frequency spectrum
for detecting gravitational wave from
seismic noise to thermal noise to shot
noise and so if we can improve the
equipment so those are technological
advances that we are working on and we
have in the laboratories where or these
people work and all over the country we
have young young people working on
things like using quantum physics to
squeeze light so we can get a bit better
focus on the laser light source for LIGO
so we're trying to reduce increase the
sensitivity reduce the noise and thereby
be able to checked sources of
gravitational ways much farther out it's
already this in this run that we're
having now which is called the second
run of this facility we have improved by
a factor of twenty to thirty percent the
sensitivity so we'll keep going in that
direction while also building a lot of
new telescopes to observe dark energy
dark matter in the ways you talked about
and you hope to reach a factor of three
right at least in your sensitivity yes
yeah but yes I know that you have
thought quite a bit and presumably still
work on this thing called non Gaussian
ET in the Cosmic Microwave Background so
you know everything in life we think is
Gaussian you know it depends on this
bell-shaped curve but in the cosmic
microwave bright background everything
is also Gaussian but different theories
predict small you know deviation from
this Gaussian ET so explain to us a
little bit you know what is involved
there and what does
mean if it is being detected yeah so I
think the the first thing to point out
is that we are always looking for things
that are left over from the very
beginning and that the subsequent
evolution of the universe has a
difficult time changing so for example
natural thing that we would look try to
receive the universe has a different
composition in different places but even
a universe that started with different
compositions some physical processes in
between can make the composition all the
same so you can erase erase composition
differences however when we look at the
statistics of these fluctuations this
property they have C and the oven is
something that is pretty much impossible
to - at least on the very large scales
to erase and so in that sense it's kind
of a very nice thing to look at because
if we find it it's telling us something
about really the very beginning of how
these fluctuations that lead to
structure arose what it involves doing
in terms of the observations is making
maps of the universe as big as you
possibly can because these are
statistical measurements so you want a
lot of samples to be able to infer the
distribution of matter and difference on
different size scales and at different
times in the history of the universe so
the bigger the map the better and and
try to learn how to interpret this in
the best possible way so just a small
follow up on this I mean can you do you
think we can do this with the current
existing data from Planck and W map or
so on or does this need the next
generation of Cosmic Microwave
Background
well these are things that the last
generation of CMB experiments made a big
big progress on that but basically in
the CMA we've mapped the entire sky
almost up to the highest resolution that
we can possibly do it there is we can do
better in polarization so there is a
little bit of improvement but not a
qualitative improvement so I think most
probably to get a not just a little bit
of an improvement which of course is
very nice
to heaven and we're working people are
working on it will happen but to have an
another order of magnitude we will
probably need to look for some other
probes mainly mapping the distribution
of matter in the later universe and and
there the current constraints on
Gaussian ET from those from those
surveys are are significantly weaker
than the ones that we have in the CMB so
it means that this field has to catch up
quite a bit
learn how to do things and it'll be the
next few generations of surveys that
will do this and eventually hopefully
they'll catch up because indeed but
there's a big part of the universe we
have not yet map so in terms of our the
data that it's out there there's a lot
nema you know we talked about you know
some of these things that that you know
we now know and some of the problems
that we have I know that such people is
Sabah's Demopoulos and some of his
students and ex students and so on work
on tabletop experiments which you know I
mean now Matias now talked about you
know bigger experiments and so on but
this is a new type of experiments that
perhaps can probe some of the things
we're talking about dark energy dark
matter you know and so can you explain a
little bit to us how those tabletop
experiments work yeah I just put it in a
little bit of context so we've certainly
the generation of people like me and
Matias have have lived through three
decades of amazing experiments probing
fundamental physics on every possible
frontier on there's dark matter as the
measurements at the universe colliders
most recently the LHC and mostly these
experiments were imagined and conceived
by people in the 1980s who had a sort of
vision for what the next 30 years was
going to look like and many of these
experiments are in their last stages and
it's I think a very interesting time to
think about what the next 30 years are
going to look like because that's the
kind of time scale we talk about in this
business you really have to think sort
of three decades on day
least yeah if not if not longer it's
getting longer so that there are of
course there's a there's a whole very
important new generation of experiments
that Matthias was just alluding to to
measure everything we possibly can about
the distribution of matter in the
universe there's I figure out the factor
is but maybe a factor of what is it like
ten to the eight times more data
potentially out there that we can get as
human being hundred million hundred me
then then what what we actually have
there's the experiments I alluded to
earlier about taking the sort of next
big step after the Large Hadron Collider
a factor of ten seven ten and energy
higher than that but there are some
novel things that people are talking
about which are mostly targeted at
looking for things that might be out
there that could be related to dark
matter that are incredibly weakly
interacting with us now dark matter is
is one of the things that's supposed to
be incredibly weakly interacting with
less par excellence right that we're
supposed to think that it that that
we've only noticed its effects
gravitationally and in gravity is by far
the weakest of all interactions there
are so most of the experiments over the
last twenty years that have been looking
for dark matter have been assuming and
there's various good theoretical reasons
why it's nice to assume so I've been
assuming that the Dark Matter particle
does participate in some of the
interactions that we we know about the
weak interactions that are associated
with radioactivity are an incredibly
weak interaction but still it's strong
enough that people could design all
these amazing experiments to look for
dark matter particles and in the range
that they're looking for that's sort of
one of them and every leader in this
room you know moving through the room at
one one-thousandth the speed of light
and they would bang into like very cold
big vats of liquid xenon for example and
you look for the little shakings of the
wrinkly as' of these atoms so that's the
kind of experiments of people in doing
for a long time but it's possible that
Dark Matter doesn't no result oh yeah no
reason we haven't seen anything now now
these things are called
this picture for dark matter is called
the picture of whips the W and whip
stands for weakly interacting massive
particles and the week is actually it
really is a technical sense of the word
the weak interactions it has that kind
of strength interaction it's actually
possible that the dark matter even is
very simple picture of wimps but that
the interaction is just too weak in fact
the very very simplest dumbest most
straightforward possible picture for
what dark matter could be it just
accidentally happens to be so weakly
coupled of these experiments are not
going to us see them but there have been
also long been many other interesting
examples of particles that could that
could solve many theoretical problems
and also be dark matter things like
accion's right and these are an
interesting kind of particle there are
zillions of them surrounding us all the
time they have very small mass there's
zillions of them surrounding us all the
time there are more strongly interacting
than gravity but way weakly more weakly
interacting than than everything else
and so you need a totally different kind
of experiment to go looking for them and
what the this new generation of
experiment that you're referring to use
cool methods from atomic physics the our
growing ability to quantum mechanically
manipulate fairly macroscopic objects in
order to look for these things just just
to give you one example if these
particles are out there and they're dark
matter one of the predictions is that
the neutrons the neutron which is a
neutral particle would have a tiny
so-called electric dipole moment that
would mean that that that it would be as
if the anu tron while to neutral has a
little bit more charge in one direction
in the north pole than in the south pole
if it's spinning with it with a spin
going in the north-south direction and
so and that tiny tiny electric dipole
moment would actually oscillate with
time and so you can use fancy methods
from atomic physics it's essentially
using the same ideas from nuclear
magnetic resonance to pick up and
amplify that that oscillating neutron
electric table just to say nuclear
magnetic resonance is what is used in
all your MRI imaging and so on so that's
that's one example and there and there
are a number of other examples like this
but there's this
frontier of looking for very weakly
interacting things that could be if
they're if the dark matter could be
filling the universe around us and
that's I think it's very exciting
right and maybe I should also add and
maybe you can add a little bit to I mean
some of these experiments also do these
things with tiny tiny micron sized
objects and you know in acting in grab
gravity between such things which is a
force that's just about the weight of a
virus ya know and testing how gravity
changes on this type of scale that's
just so you have an idea what we we
often say the gravity is the weakest of
all forces and if you take a if you take
a pair of electrons they're they're
electric repulsion is forty two orders
of magnitude stronger than the
gravitational attraction between them
that's one in 4000 yeah so now of course
gravity looks like the most important
force here it's keeping our feet to the
ground and and and and so on and that's
because most objects are and in the end
electrically neutral right like atoms
are electrically neutral but but you can
ask at what distance if you take a pair
of hydrogen atoms at what distance you
have to put them so that gravity gets
weaker than even the residual tiny tiny
little piece of the electromagnetic
interaction that's left between them
it's called the van der Waals force it
turns out that that distance is around a
millimeter and already at a millimeter
which is a pretty big distance scale
gravity is just getting swamped by by
these other interactions and so indeed
there are there are people who managed
to control for example the quantum
mechanical coherence between two atoms
that are separated by distances of this
of this order so you could actually try
to measure and see the effects of
gravity on these very small scale things
friends we heard here of you know large
scale experiments and tabletop type
experiments you know and so how does the
NSF work in terms of prioritizing or not
big versus small experiments and so on
because we're talking here about
different classes
of experiments thinks that cost billions
of dollars and thinks that our tabletop
experiments which probably still cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars maybe
but you know it's ten like so it's it's
an interesting question for many aspects
because of course you know even though
we have in principle seven and a half
billion dollars to spend it's it's just
a drop in the bucket when it comes to
funding our science and engineering and
so it's the question of how one sets
one's priorities and how you balance
little versus big things to invest in
because you want to have an investment
portfolio we all want to in our personal
lives that that balances four different
objectives and goals in house a balanced
portfolio so we really depend on the
science in engineering community to be
the major source of input for that but
believe me we get a lot of input from
other sources too one major source of
input is the National Academy of
Sciences so especially in astronomy in
physics we have these reports that come
out every decade or five years for the
high energy physics thing every few
years and those are those represents
hundreds even thousands of scientists
and engineers coming together and decide
and having these kinds of conversations
just like this only really intense about
know if we just build you know this kind
of detector then even though it'll take
ten years and so on and so they put all
that together in a report that Congress
really respects because it represents
different input than the agency itself
and we we pretty much follow the
guidelines of those reports we just draw
the boundary at how much money we have
to fund them and so we have we fund very
big things that cost hundreds of
millions of dollars like I mentioned and
like oh altogether we've put in a
billion dollars plus and we fund we have
a program called major research
instrumentation in universities that
funds up to four million dollar projects
that the area that we're most worried
about leaving out right now is is the
area in the middle that costs anywhere
from say ten to a hundred million
because we don't have specific pots of
money designed for that much yes I want
to turn a slightly provocative here in
the following sense you know we've we've
been looking for Dark Matter now for a
long time and we've not found anything
now it is true that the dark matter
particles they have a lot of where to
hide but still we have not found
anything so there are a few people there
not very many right now but there are a
few people one of them happens to be a
good friend of mine who suggests that
there are no such dark matter particles
that instead we need to change our
theory and there have been historical
precedents to this I mean you know like
when Einstein was there and there was a
third you know and so on the idea was
not to have something that you don't see
but to change the theory so and
similarly with the precession of mercury
right we have to change the theory at
what point if any do we say well maybe
we shouldn't build even a bigger
experiment or not let's think harder of
changing the theory well whenever there
if there comes a theory that explains
everything and more things then
everybody will jump of course so what a
problem is the lack of the such a theory
but also it's important to realize that
dark matter was introduced as you know
because of discrepancies in galaxies and
clusters of galaxies but that's nowhere
not at all now from where we get most of
our information or all of our
information about how dark much dark
matter there is or how it is distributed
it's from the Cosmic Microwave
Background
it's from gravitational lensing all
things that were not were not there when
dark matter first the first anomalies
that led to people to think about the
dark matter came about and and so now
the
to try to if you want to have another
explanation which by the way it's
totally fine I think it's great to try
to have a and a lot of people do it and
it's not a problem at all but the were
you where you have to focus your
attention in my opinion is on the things
that where its most constraining where
we have the most information percent
measurements of the you know abundance
because of how it was distributed
400,000 years after the Big Bang and in
the middle with a gravitational lensing
and later with galaxy clustering so we
have so much information and
unfortunately even you mentioned some of
these frameworks they were built to
explain the original anomalies right but
they have nothing to say about all of
modern cosmology I would say and so it's
there so at the moment so lacking of of
being able to use in anywhere where the
excitement is that that's the reason
most people are not using it for
cosmology because it has nothing to say
III agree with you but I were just a
small follow-up I mean partly you know
maybe I'm just you know raising them as
it was a provocative possibility most
people didn't accept these new
frameworks to begin with and so maybe
not enough people have thought about
this you're right that these frameworks
don't explain the peaks in the Cosmic
Microwave Background but maybe because
not enough people thought of trying to
it I don't think that's totally correct
people have tried people came up with
ways and try to implement them and they
didn't work out so there are people that
are continuing to try just to mention
somebody just inquiry or Linda Berlin
there are many people that are right
trying to do it so it's not the case
that and you know I I think people
should not take the do not should not
think that in any way shape or form we
are not trying to find the answer right
so if there's an idea in and and people
you know especially theories they like
to speculate and whenever there is
something that rings a little bit true
they follow up the problem is that they
follow up and you know the typical
complain about the theorist
is that there is one event and there's a
you know at the LHC or whatever and a
hundred papers so every you know
theories we follow up everything and the
reason these things have not picked up
in my opinion is because the grains of
truth that you know ring then when you
follow them up so far they lead to
nowhere right while on the other hand
dark matter as a particle we have to
remember the universe was much harder
than anything but no collisions were
much higher energy than anything we are
probably in the laboratory there's more
general there's a more general point
here which is often when when we talk
about dark matter and dark energy
especially in context like this there is
a there's an obvious question there's
always some twelve-year-old kid in the
audience isn't it just like the ether
you you guys are idiots you haven't
learned anything you know like every
time you have a problem you like invent
some do crazy things that's supposed to
build build the universe and we know
that we of course of course we we know
that the problem with history and if you
know anything about history of science
you know that you can use you can take
an example from history to illustrate
any polemic point you want to make in
the in the case of a dark matter you
alluded to already but there are there
were there were two ways there were both
ways and there was actually one
astronomer Levite who was involved in
both of them mr. Laval EA predicted the
location of Neptune because there were
some little anomalies in in the orbits
of the distant planets and so that was
dark matter back then dark planet was
you could all said oh oh let's mess up
Newton's laws but know the right thing
was conservative almost always the right
thing is conservative that's right
then he predicted Vulcan because there
was something wrong with the orbit of
mercury and he was wrong in that case
right so that the same guy was white
sites and wrong ones so we never know
ahead of time and that's why we always
keep an open mind especially I'm just
echoing with what Matthias said
especially its theoretical physicists we
keep a very open mind as Robert
Oppenheimer said it's important to keep
an open mind not so open that your
brains fall out but you try to keep your
mind as open as possible and that's
really the difficult I've spent time
thinking about modified gravity and
written papers about it but exactly what
Matthias said is right that there's a
certain smell of truth
of logical consistency of inevitability
of something that works which is is
nowhere near any of the attempt so far
it doesn't mean there might not be one
someday but it's not like we're
dogmatically beating people over the
head who dare challenge Einstein believe
me if we could challenge on sanity right
we were the greatest thing we could
possibly do so so the the the the the
difficulty in this subject is how to be
radical and conservative at the same
time and especially given that so much
works so well already you can't just go
crashing everything because because we
have this incredible edifice that we
built up over four hundred years that's
why we don't know ahead of time how
radical and how conservative to be and
we try everything we can there's another
point here so it we talked a little bit
about the gravitational wave observatory
and this is the first time in the
history of the planet that we now have
an observatory that can detect sources
of gravitational waves so what did the
first three sources turn out to be
something that we didn't even know
existed not something that that can't
exist but nobody was running around
writing papers about binary black holes
especially of those kinds of masses of
2030 solar masses and now we know that
there's probably a very large population
so I asked one of your contemporaries
theorist Ed Witten and at MIT I said is
is it possible that they could form a
constituent of dark matter and he said
actually in it's interesting question
because in parameter space there there
is a place for them to form you know not
all of it but but how do we know you
know we're just you set up and you
invent a new kind of technology that can
can detect the universe in a whole new
way you discover class of sources maybe
there are many classes of sources and
they don't have to be like that but but
that's that's just the beauty of what
we're involved in right now is that
we're always discovering something new
that's going to shed some light and who
knows if that those will be connected to
the dark matter question they're
certainly connected to the evolution of
the universe in some way very quickly
about that since you since there was
something
at the very end of your question to
Matthias you said shouldn't we just
might might we better not be served by
by thinking about something new rather
than doing more and more complicated
experiments I think I know I know you're
being provocative but but I think the
answer is theorists or theorists and do
what there is do were cheap but we
should do every conceivable experiment
we can that we can do using the
technology the greatest technology we
have at any time to learn more about the
universe experimentally because
surprises happen every single time we do
that's right
Nima i want to ask you and this this
particular concept that i'm going to
bring up now actually raises the blood
pressure of many of my friends but i
know it doesn't raise your blood
pressure and neither of matias i want to
bring about the multiverse so basically
in recent years i think it's fair to say
that it's fairly recent i mean it's been
around for a while but but not that long
theorists have come up with the idea and
there are all kinds of reasons for this
that maybe our entire universe is not
all there is but rather this is one
member of a huge ensemble which could be
10 to the 500 1 followed by 500 or it
could even be perhaps infinite how it
infinite yeah of universes and the
reason our universe has the properties
it has is because those have to be
consistent more or less with the fact
that we are here namely the values of
the constants of nature and the laws of
physics have such that they have allowed
our them but there are many other
universes which in which the laws may be
different the constants of nature may be
different and so on there are colleagues
I'm sure you're very aware of that
regard this concept as the end of
physics
I want you because why do they say the
end of physics because they say oh well
since these other universes are not
observable then this becomes more like
metaphysics and not like physics because
you cannot test it and so on
now I happen to know that you believe
that this is not the case and I want you
now to explain this a little bit
yeah well the discussion is is multi
person use I mean they don't raise my
blood blood pressure because of because
I think there's something intellectually
long wrong with talking about it
although my blood pressure does increase
because any enormous amount of nonsense
that's said about it in both directions
both in the in in pro and con con
direction so let me just say one thing
just before just to set the context for
the discussion even the theory the idea
that there's a multiverse is not a
theory yes it's not even a theory at the
level that we're used to in theoretical
physics there's all kinds of things that
we talk about that we have not yet
verified are there in nature for example
things like supersymmetry
ideas like that these deserve to be
called theories because we understand
the the theoretical structure well
enough to know what we're talking about
to make to say if this and this and that
is true then we can make a lot of other
predictions that may or may not be
realized in nature but it still deserves
to be called a theory it's we understand
the the ingredients the multiverse is
not like that it's at the the ideas and
concepts involved with the multiverse or
at the very edge of the things that we
even conceptually know how to talk about
I think of it as a caricature for
something that might be true it doesn't
even rise to the level of a theory yet
how do you write so let me let me say
just take take them take some of the
problems one once at a time one of the
ingredients that you need for something
for a picture like the multiverse to be
right is many but you many approximate
vacuums that one underlying set of laws
could have and that's the still get for
one second I mean a vacuum is
distinguished we would call a universe
at some level or a pocket universe so
you can have many vacuum it's a lower
sort of lowest possible lowest energy
state that that we can have where you
just empty everything out right and and
hopefully in an expanding universe
that's what happens as the universe
expands everything gets more and more
dilute
and you approach more and more the
lowest energy configuration now it's not
a crazy possibility in fact it happens
all the time in our simplest series of a
particle physics that you could have
theories where where where you could
have a lowest possible energy state and
another energy state that could have a
different energy and and you could get
stuck in these sort of local places
where we're locally you have the
smallest amount of energy but in order
to go to find the place where you have
the lowest possible energy you've got to
go far away and somewhere else
the second that becomes possible we can
entertain the idea that that that these
different possible approximately stable
places could exist that piece of the
multiverse could in principle be
verified by experiments in our universe
that could be in principle verified so
I'll give you an example now now we
don't wait since we don't know the we
don't know the the energies involved but
for the barriers between one local
minimum here another local minimum there
those energies could be gargantuan they
could be much much higher than energy
and any energy that we could make in
sync of a landscape which has valleys
but with wind and there can be huge
mountain exactly there are just enormous
mountains but if you have enough energy
to climb over the enormous mountains
then you could make little bubbles of
the other regions and you can really
make them you could make them in a
laboratory you could send little
elementary particles in and say oh gosh
I'm the Higgs particle out here I have
this mass in there I have a different
mass Wow and it comes back out you can
actually see all of that you could in
principle see that there is ten to the
five hundred different possibilities all
of that you could actually in principle
definitely not in practice as far as we
can tell but but but in principle it's
not a question of philosophy it is a
question of a physics what we don't know
how to do and this is the deepest
conceptual problem associated with the
multiverse and and if someone were to
make a theoretical breakthrough on this
question it could settle certainly in my
thinking is I'm sure in Mateus isn't
almost all of our thinking whether this
idea is is is a deep one or a crack one
okay we still don't don't know the
deepest conceptual problem is how are
these different regions realize out
there in the universe and what you
alluded to the fact that in our
accelerating universe we only have
access to what we see now is what we're
ever going to see so if there are these
other regions out there light from them
will never
to us even in principle that's a good
reason to be suspicious about whether it
actually makes sense to invoke them and
talk about them we don't know if it
makes sense to invoke them or talking
about them invoking and talking about
them is a little bit like invoking and
talking about what's on the other side
of a black hole of the horizon of a
black hole and you know in the last 20
years we've understood that there is
some subtle way that the quantum
mechanics lets you see into the inside
of a black hole and get the information
about what's in there out so it's
possible that similarly there's some
very subtle way in which quantum effects
now apply to the entire universe will
help us make sense of what what's going
on behind the horizon out there in the
multiverse but this is the part which is
totally speculation at this point but
but imagine we did the experiments that
show that these 10 to the 500 different
the environments existed it would be
very hard not to believe that there
should be that that they play some role
in in controlling the properties of our
world and that part is not philosophy
that part is actually if it's right I I
just want to add two things one very
simple and one a little bit more subtle
and one is that you see at the time
there was this great astronomer Johannes
Kepler and he was really very smart and
he was the great astronomer and he
thought that he can explain why in the
solar system there are exactly six
planet six were known at this time
because he thought that that is a
fundamental property of the universe
which can be explained from first
principles today we know that's an
accident really in this way it could in
principle be that some properties of our
universe which we now regard as
fundamental are in fact accidental and
you know they get different values in
these different members of the ensemble
materials I'll ask you one more question
and then I want to leave enough time for
the audience to ask questions as well
you alluded to this but I just want to
sharpen it a little bit the very early
universe is relatively simple
you know only fundamental things happen
there
but it is also far away and not that
easy to observe the nearby universe we
can observe more easily but it's a mess
because it involves all kinds of
processes of star formation in plant
information in galaxy formation and
whatnot and so on
is there a sweet spot somewhere where
you know you get the benefit of both
worlds well I think the clear sweet spot
is the crossing microbe a girl in the
history of the universe it is more or
less much more in between and that
perhaps are calling it the early
universe but it's 400,000 years after
the Big Bang so that's pretty late for a
lot of depends but so that's then it's
true it gets more and more complicated
and that's for example when we were
talking about the discussions about dark
matter when we start using our theories
for dark matter try to understand
galaxies are small enough things for
let's take galaxies for example they are
getting into trouble sometimes they
don't seem to work and that's the reason
why people also are trying to find other
but it's also the case that all of the
complications you unlooted to star
formation the black holes in the Centers
of each galaxies they play a big role we
see it with our own eyes meaning the
telescope so the more complicated things
get sometimes it's difficult to
disentangle and that's why in cosmology
we try to get out you know just use
galaxies for example as points not too
much try to understand how they're made
of but just tracing where the matter is
distributed we never know where we will
be able to make some breakthrough and
there there are certain things that you
just have to leave to the side even if
there are a very interesting problem but
you have to leave it to the side because
it doesn't look like there's any no
progress is being made and it's kind of
a business of the the game is like this
you speculate you try to look for things
you go on from there I would like to
open this for questions from the
audience okay it's a wonderful panel
thank you obviously mankind when we
discovered electrons it changed
world we now have electricity all these
wonderful things now all these new more
particles that you're discovering
fermions and quarks and all these items
are we on the verge of taking these
particles and revolutionising our
existence as humans we don't know what
the what what fundamental breakthroughs
in science will eventually give Michael
Faraday famously when he was doing his
experiments on magnetism in the basement
of the world Institute in London some
British MP visited and said what is this
good for he said I don't know sir but
one day you will tax it and and that
happened fifty years later can I think
at the moment of any practical
technological application of the
discovery of the Higgs particle no
however when you get large groups of
people to do very very hard things they
they inevitably have to come up with
innovations that have lots of other
impacts a classic example from the field
you were talking about is he mentioned
the World Wide Web which was invented at
CERN to help experimentalists share this
enormous amount of data with each other
so even though I had nothing to do with
the particles that they asked actually
discovered when you have people pursuing
pure ends very difficult problems that
are right on the frontier of what we
know how to do good things always come
out of it or have historically but we
also never do it for we don't do it for
this reason right that's right if you
want to think about what's gonna be
exciting in technology ten years from
now talk to people in Silicon Valley if
you want to wonder what might be
exciting 50 or 100 years from now it's
gonna come out of fundamental science
yes please
so if new technology reveals new
theories can we ever reach a final
theory and since all our theories
currently evolved from the Big Bang does
anyone question the Big Bang now I'm
happy to take one shot at this and say
that what I think we're all we've all
been doing is pushing the frontier
farther and backwards in time all the
time and when people talk about you know
a final theory I mean
Lord Kelvin famously thought at the end
of the 19th century that all problems in
physics were solved except for two small
problems and those two small problems
actually turned out to lead to general
relativity and quantum mechanics so
during big revolutions in physics so I
think that we have now discovered that
the more we push we find new questions
so it's not I I don't see any danger
that we will run out of questions to
answer at any point in time so you know
in in those terms no theory is truly
final theories in physics are really you
know only theories that are good for the
data available at a given time but as
new data become available
I mean you sometimes have to modify a
theory sometimes it becomes incorporated
in a bigger framework like in Newton's
theory being incorporated in general
relativity let's say sometimes it has to
be rejected altogether and so on and in
this process I believe will continue
forever so that's the process we're
going that the Big Bang itself is not a
fear it's an observation it's a
collection of pictures from the past and
pictures and things that we got from the
past so that will never go away it's not
it's just what I think that maybe I'll
echo the same thing and make a slightly
more general point as well something I
think many people don't appreciate is
that there's very really grand questions
about the universe that that that all of
us get excited about some fraction rest
aside this is what we want to do with
their lives and we and we attack them
but there's something really fascinating
as your as your understanding of the
world becomes precise enough so that
things really work the character of the
questions change changes the language
with which you describe the questions
changes and very often the actual
questions evolve but we don't even know
what the right questions are until we
happen to be in the
of the correct answers and as we happen
to learn more so you should not have
this idea that we have this sort of
fixed set of questions we've been
working on for 2,000 years and we're
getting closer and closer and we might
hit the end it's something much more
interesting is happening that that we're
learning more and deeper and more
profound things about the world that's
allowing us to ask entirely new kinds of
questions things that we weren't even
questions before become questions and so
on I'm going back to what matthias said
we have as much evidence as we'll and
we'll only get more that the Erb there
the universe is expanding is you run the
picture backward in time that got denser
and hotter and and that hot dense early
period of the universe is what we
colloquially call the Big Bang what
you're referring to as a Big Bang and
many prefer people refer to the Big Bang
it's this sort of mathematical
singularity of a point where everything
starts back in time and that's the thing
which we don't understand we don't
understand and what's very likely going
on is is that the whole notion of time
is breaking down there it's not a
question to figure out what came before
that the whole notion of time was
probably born there or it's certainly
breaking down there and if that sounds
like a very tall order to figure out
what it means it is a tall order to
figure out what it means okay and that's
what people are trying their best to you
know take little bits and pieces off
that problem and make some progress on
it is these gentlemen over here is it
felt that the universe is infinite and
if it is felt to be infinite in what
sense is it infinite and how did
something that was finite become
infinite in finite time the easy answer
will either say that we only see us some
region of the universe and what's
outside I have no idea that would be the
standard answer that I would give I
don't know if it's infinite or if it's
curved and it comes back and it's like
the surface of a ball and it's really
infinite we don't know for all we see we
don't see any curvature of this ball we
when we see further away things look
more or less the same so it does it
looks pretty much on more genius we
clearly see that if it you know finishes
or it has a curvature it's much bigger
the region that looks like the part of
the universe that we can see this
probably goes on for a while other than
that we don't really know
also how these start these started is
also some of the you know these are
questions whose answer we don't know and
whether or not is our universe is
connected to places which are completely
different and it's so much bigger than
that what we see and the laws of physics
are completely different but just there
one thing about the question of a
finiteness because something very
important happened in the late 1990s
when we discovered the universe was
accelerating which is what we see in the
universe whatever you might imagine in
your mind's eye the universe going on
and on that's what we've been referring
to because the universe is accelerating
what we see now in the universe is what
we're ever gonna see that's kind of an
amazing thing if the universe was not
accelerating if there was a picture from
what people talked about in the books in
the 1980s and the universe just kept
expanding forever then it would be an
experimental question if it was infinite
or not if you waited long enough you're
a great-great-great-great
great-great-great grandchildren would
see more and more and more and more of
the universe we can't now I mean what we
see now it was what we're ever going
going to see and so it's relating that
the acceleration of I'll make I'll make
this even sharper if the universe
continues to accelerate as it does then
maybe a trillion years from now
actually if astronomers still live here
they were not able to see anything right
nobody never galaxy just our galaxy that
will be and then all these stories about
the universe you know this would be like
mythology okay can we have this young
woman here if there is a multiverse how
would our universe like interact with
the other universes how would that work
do we know do you want to say something
yeah well most obviously it wouldn't
that's one of the problems that's that's
one of the conceptual problems is that
all of this stuff is out there and it's
beyond our cosmological horizon which
because we're accelerating where we
won't see what we won't see in any of
that stuff
now that might make you think that and
we've gotten very weary in physics for
many good reasons we've gotten very
wary of concepts and ideas that we can't
even in principle see and what I'm just
talking about is not a question of
practicality right our acceleration
makes it impossible for life from those
regions to too delicious to reach us
now it's conceivable sometimes people
talk about if we came from some parent
underlying vacuum that that gave rise to
us that there could be other little
bubbles and those bubbles could collide
with each other this is something that
the people talk about it's an
in-principle possibility I have to tell
you it's it's so vanishingly unlikely to
happen that if you hear about it in the
press you should be very skeptical it's
not I mean even theoretically it's
incredibly unlikely for it for it to
happen but it is in principle possible
now but having said all of this and this
is part of the reason it's theoretically
difficult if it was clear that nothing
about these other vacuo these other
regions could have any effect on us at
all then we would be almost certain that
it's garbage and we shouldn't think
about it but it's not a hundred percent
obvious and the reason is that you can
imagine other parts or you can imagine
futures that we could have where if we
exited our vacuum but we went into
another kind of vacuum in the future
those observers could look back and look
at the night sky and see eventually if
they waited long enough
all these collisions happening with all
these other bubbles and they could see
if you waited long enough there's
somebody that could see the entire
multiverse it's not us but in principle
there are some people that be waited
long enough you could but but anyway but
the short answer to your question is in
no conceivable way we can imagine now
other than these vanishingly unlikely
things involving collisions with bubbles
thank you very much neem I think the
panel and thank all of you for attending
you
[Music]